i
[Música]
ah
cerca del 30 de las camas de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos están
ocupadas por pacientes con kobe 19 lo
que en términos absolutos se traduce en
unos 2.800 ingresados en la actualidad
por esta razón y si nos fijamos en las
cifras de hace un mes vemos como ha
habido un aumento de más de 10 puntos
pero estamos hablando de la situación en
general de la media de españa pero es
especialmente preocupante en 9
comunidades autónomas donde esta cifra
de ocupación supera el 35% es el caso de
la rioja de aragón de cataluña o de
madrid entre otras y lo que preocupa
sobre todo al personal sanitario es que
a pesar de que se conozca mejor la
enfermedad y por lo tanto se pueda
procurar también un mejor tratamiento
que mejore las expectativas de las
personas que ingresan en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos si continúan a los
contagios en aumento se puede llegar de
nuevo a un colapso hospitalario que
genere una fuerte competencia entre
pacientes tanto cobit cómo no kobe por
obtener una cama en estas unidades
[Música]
francia volvió a confinarse y sin
embargo los casos de coronavirus siguen
aumentando de manera exponencial de
hecho durante la primera semana de
noviembre que fue también la primera
semana de confinamiento se llegaron
hasta los 4000 casos de ingreso en
reanimación de pacientes con comida de
19 a sabiendas de que en francia hay
unas 6.000 camas en estos servicios a
diferencia de la primavera francia no
podrá esta vez enviar pacientes a los
países vecinos ya que en toda europa se
está luchando contra esta epidemia por
ahora ha habido transferencia de
pacientes entre diferentes regiones y
también de hospitales públicos hacia
clínicas privadas
olivia de ron el ministro de salud
indicaba que el espera haya un pico del
número de ingresos en reanimación cerca
de 6000 hacia mediados de noviembre que
a partir de ese momento esas cifras
deberían comenzar a disminuir pero
teniendo en cuenta un promedio bastante
importante y es que 1 de cada 4
pacientes que ingresa en reanimación no
suele salir con vida
[Música]
bélgica con la incidencia de casos más
elevada de europa de coronavirus está
desbordada a diferencia de la primera
ola los hospitales han estado en las
últimas semanas al borde de quedarse sin
camas y de unidades de cuidados
intensivos por ello el gobierno ha
lanzado un plan para que haya 800 camas
adicionales en los hospitales para hacer
frente a la avalancha de casos a partir
de ahora los hospitales tendrán que
dedicar un 60% de camas a los pacientes
más graves de coronavirus en las últimas
semanas el país ha puesto medidas mucho
más restrictivas como el 'toque de
queda' también el cierre de la
hostelería también de las tiendas para
que se reduzcan los casos de hecho se
han ralentizado pero aún así los casos
siguen siendo muy elevados así lo alerta
el personal sanitario que asegura que a
pesar de todo no hay que bajar la
guardia porque en la transmisión
comunitaria del virus sigue siendo muy
elevada en todo el país
[Música]